[Music]
good evening and
members members of the public officers
uh welcome to this planning committee
meeting on the 15th of june
1919 2022
uh housekeeping as always if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices via the stairs
either through the security door
to my right
or
by the stairs where you came into the
chamber please do not use the lifts
assemble on halley square the green
virtual opposite the council offices
and if safe to do so an officer will
bring you back in to the meeting
uh does anybody intend filming the
meeting this evening
can they please show their hands
no thank you very much
uh restriction of mobile phones now
just a little bit different on this one
if i may um as members once again and
members of the public i will ask you not
to use your phones please turn them to
silent and please do not make calls or
receive or answer emails during the
meeting
uh this exception
i'm giving tonight is to councillor joel
bayford
um without too much detail i do know her
daughter
is unwell
and
i think it's fair that she
hopefully she doesn't receive any calls
regarding her so
thank you
members wishing to speak on
um under
well 20.1
is councillor pew speaking
under 5 a
on gender item 5a
also i have a council lease on item 5
c
are there any other members not on the
committee
so
i can see you
can you
uh toning thank you councillor towning
it you're miles up there and i've got my
reading glasses on so
and
i know
i shouldn't ignore him
and item
council town in
five
is that 5c as well
thank you
also remind members and the members of
the public that this meeting is being
live streamed
on the council's youtube channel
public speaking the following
applications have been reserved for
public speaking would members please
note
that the following items on their agenda
item 5a
land south west of
of waste processing plant on the manson
road north manson
item 5b
former british gas site at north down
road bull says
an item 5c
41 princess margaret avenue in margate
agenda item 1 apologies for this
evening's meeting i have apologies for
councillor everett councillor keane
uh councillor paul moore
are there any other apologies
setting in for
do we have anyone sitting in for council
more or council no
okay thank you
agenda item two declarations of interest
are there any members
have interest and gender items
thank you
agenda item three minutes of the
planning committee meeting held on the
18th of may do members agree that the
minutes of the planning committee held
on the 18th of may
2022 be approved as a correct record
could i have a proposal please
thank you council heart a second up
please
counselor george bayford uh do your
degree
thank you members
agenda item four
seven seacroft road brawl says
this was the site visit which we had
last week i'm going to hand over to mr
livingston to outline the report
thank you chair
so the application is for the erection
of a first floor rear extension with a
balcony over a single story rear
extension at seven seacroft
roads so we have uh the site outlined in
red as you can see on the screen
you have a neighbor at the rear which is
number nine
and then you have joseph's court which
is the building
to the right-hand side of the image so
to the east of the site
so the main consideration that members
wanted to assess was the impact on the
living conditions of the property
adjacent which is joseph court so i'll
just go through the application
uh
just to show members with the photos so
this is the aerial image of the site so
you can see the host site in the center
of the the image
this is the view from the road of the
property in question so it's not a
concern of officers about the impact on
the character appearance the area from
the first floor extension because it's
behind this building so it's not visible
in the public realm
then this is the access down to a
communal
parking area that serves um
joseph's court um so the
the window and door that you can see on
the left-hand side of the image there
serve number number three joseph's court
which is
the property that members viewed
this is the rear parking area
this is the view from that area to where
the extension would be so it's above the
single story accretion here
center the image
this is the kitchen window
that is raised in the report as the the
main consideration as to whether or not
there is an impact from the balcony
and members were able to access
the kitchen
to look through that window to see the
location of the balcony
this is just a view from in front of
that window towards
the balcony and then this is around the
other side of joseph's court the access
to the other property sorry it's number
two and three are accessed there it's
number one
uh that's affected
so
this is the location of the extension uh
in the center of the image
this is the side election that you could
see from the photos and then this is the
proposal so
the application was amended during the
course of the submission to increase the
height of the balustrading to 1.4 meters
above the finish floor level of the
balcony
and with that balustrading to be obscure
glazed sort of a glazed screen
which would avoid any prolonged
overlooking if there were tables and
chairs that were situated on that
balcony
it is considered by officers
that the impact on the neighbouring
property is acceptable by virtue of the
existing relationship with
if i just skip through to show you the
here we go um
the existing relationship with the
access to the rear area
as well as um the angle
serving from the balcony looking towards
that window
this is an image that was provided by
the applicant
which shows
the view that you get a little bit lower
down the way the window is members will
recall looking at this image last time
committee
and this is the the kitchen window in
question
and then this is the floor plan of
joseph's court and
this is the the kitchen in question um
that members were able to actually go
into and see from so in in officer's
opinion it is not considered that the um
the impact of overlooking is is
unacceptable from the proposal
and therefore it is recommended for
approval thank you chair
uh thank you ian i move the officer's
recommendation for approval
is adopted for the vice chair please
second
or second nation thank you council
corpsman cook
members
any debate council bayford
thank you chair um yes
i have to say i
i didn't think that with the distance
involved and the angle
of the
extension i i didn't honestly think that
the effect was unacceptable on the
neighboring properties so i'd be happy
to support the application thank you
thank you councillor zesky
thank you chair um on the site visit uh
we had a good look around
uh
normal weather everything um for a
change for a change it didn't rain um
and looking down on that window you
could see
um the glare coming off it but you
couldn't see inside
so i don't think it's a major issue
during the day um i'll be happy to
support the application
thank you councillor zesky are there any
other members
cancer shrub yeah well i went to the um
viewing and as we were
at the back of the kitchen uh where the
dining area is i could hardly see out
that window so i'll be happy to support
this one
uh thank you are there any other members
wishing to speak
thank you members okay i put this to you
so those in favor of this application
please show their hands
those against
that is carried thank you very much
members thank you
agenda item 5 is the schedule of planned
applications and public speaking
uh any site visits will take place for
committee members on friday the 8th of
july as you know normally 9 30
in the morning
agenda item 5a is the application for
refusal of land southwest of the waste
processing plant
district park mansion road north in
manson
speaking in favor of the application is
mr ryan mr ryan
would you mind speaking please and you
have three minutes
if you take one thing away from my three
minutes is this the ask for district
park is to use 18 acres of farmland that
probably doesn't even support one
full-time job to be used to support 300
jobs for the next 20 years for minimal
highways or environmental impact
thank you for your time chair and thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
speak locating kent has been funded
primarily by kent county council support
employers
that are expanding our move into the
region for over 20 years we fully
support the planning application for
district park on the basis it will
safeguard
220 people's jobs and provide capacity
to create over 80 new ones
during the planning application process
we have consistently made the case for
this application on the basis that
refusal based on land use and allocation
is not in the interest of your community
or the wider kent economy
point threes of three and four of your
office refusal reasons relate to
highways on point three the proposed
scheme is a sustainable location despite
the absence of a path the applicant's
detailed travel plan commits to funding
a car scheme and crew buses through the
section 106 agreement installing a path
is particularly expensive and delivers
no wider benefits to your community
so it's clearly not viable or necessary
and on point four the applicant has
agreed with kcc highways to make a
section 106 contribution to the
improvements at spitfire junction
the main points i wish to address are
protecting planet's landscape and the
loss of agricultural land locating kent
has a pipeline of over 20 local
manufacturers and capable of expanding
due to shortage of employment sites like
district park businesses need
well-connected sites with buildings that
meet modern sustainability standards and
provide
space for future growth
you should be aware this is a 20 to
30-year investment for the businesses
looking at district park and their
decisions need to be made today
typically local plans look forward 15
years and take five years to complete
tonight is your opportunity to fix that
imbalance
on point one as you would expect from
the responsible local developer the
applicant spent a lot of time on design
the buildings will be seen against the
backdrop of neighbouring uses and
screening means minimal impact on the
landscape therefore the jobs protected
and created through this scheme will
outweigh the minor perceived visual harm
and with only one exception the
neighbouring consultees are satisfied
this is the case on point two sites like
these exist close to not in settlements
very few villages or town sites provide
expansion space and in any case are more
valuable for residential use in fact
much of the planet's proposed urban
employment land has been lost to
residential use
despite this your recently adopted local
plan allows for thousands of houses on
greenfield sites
how can it be that employment doesn't
receive the same greenfield treatment as
your local plan stands employment land
stock is smaller now than it was in 1998
before your recently planned housing was
anticipated
alternative sites are unavailable or
unviable right now these businesses
cannot wait for planning policy to catch
up with today's needs
district park is a dispute
carry on thank you district part is a
bespoke design for the businesses and
within 15 minutes of their workforces
the site can be serviced and has good
strategic highway connections as i said
at the start if you take one thing away
from the my three minutes is this the
ask for digital park is to use 18 acres
of farmland that doesn't support even
one full-time job
to be used to support 300 jobs for the
next 20 years for minimum highways and
environmental impact thank you chair
thank you very much mr ryan speaking as
ward councillor is councillor pew
council view
thank you chair that's certainly uh
thank you mr ryan it's certainly a hard
act to follow um and i'll try not to um
you know overlay uh much with what mr
ryan has said um
you know i think it's incredibly
important this application is supported
um as the ward councillor
um not only for the villages but also as
cabinet member for economic development
i'm contacted on almost a weekly basis
by businesses that are looking to move
into the area and we don't have the
space or the nor the capacity i know
that the maple leaf business park um
further down the other side of madison
airport
you know they can't build commercial
units quick enough and you know they're
going up as quickly as they can and
they're they're filling them almost
straight away so you know i do
completely appreciate the the lack of
commercial units in space um across the
district um
my main concern i understand why the
officer recommendation is as it is
but this designate this the reason for
refusal is says that the land is
designated as agricultural land and i
think the incredibly important point to
make as
mr ryan has done is that you know we've
got thousands of homes designated on our
agricultural land and i know i have as a
ward council and many times other
applications when i've
been insisting or hoping that this
committee would refuse a residential
scheme you know my argument has always
been you know where are the jobs for all
these people where are the jobs for
these new houses you know if we can put
more significant weight to build an
agricultural land uh just for
residential use you know i find it
intriguing that we're going to reject
this honor on a technicality to do with
the policy of the local plan and when
this is an opportunity to bring hundreds
of new jobs into the area and try and
not scare away businesses that want to
come here and invest invest in planet
and
moving on to my other point about policy
and i appreciate that
clarification may be given to this later
but you know another reason was uh from
the officer's recommendation the reasons
was um
the contribution and contravening of
policy particularly to do with highways
in the spitfire junction now i can tell
you as the ward councillor that you know
there's not a residential application
that comes in my award that kcc aren't
trying to get the applicant to pay for
improvements spitfire junction it's been
happening for as long as i've been a
counsellor so for at least the last five
or six years and you know not one time
has any either any money been allocated
or has has that junction changed you
know i think it's
a bit rich now for us to try and be
insisted on having on an applicant to
make improvements to that junction or
not least refuse it on that policy
technicality and i appreciate that may
have changed but i just wanted to to
highlight that you know it's a point of
frustration for me um
i think moving on as well and you know
i'll try and try and be quick um
you know this is the land that is owned
by the applicant we've already got dds
group adjacent to the site and there is
already commercial kind of units as you
would say
um close to that that were viewed quite
a few years ago not that many years ago
actually
built on agricultural land um
as the war council i've received no
complaints from residents about this um
i'm incredibly supportive particularly
of the the bund and the significant
planting that's going to be put in place
for this site and i think it's important
that the committee
understands and appreciates uh the
economic benefit that this will bring to
the area particularly in a ward where
many people travel outside of work
outside of this ward to go to work
it's an area where i've received no real
complaints um particularly to do with
traffic movements or heavy goods
vehicles um
you know in particular as i said about
the spitfire junction and therefore i'm
hoping
and praying um the planning committee
members will support this and approve
this application so thank you
uh thank you councillor pugh
the officer now will give his report
which i believe is in
thank you chair
so the planning application is for the
erection of a series of general
industrial buildings with associated
open storage so the red line on the
image that you can see outlines
the site so just to put members in in
the location of the site
just to the south uh sort of southeast
of the red line site is the northern
grass part of the manson airport site
so down in the the bottom left of the
image is the spitfire junction and so
going up the mansion road part that's
the margate part of manston road
and
the site is outlined in red so the site
is outside the urban confines and in the
countryside
this is a satellite image taken from
google just to show the existing the
existing dds
site
is in the center of the image so where
the mouse cursor is moving around
next to it is a size of
which is the secure storage solution
site
with the site in question
application around the the rear
between this site and the charles river
site which is further to the to the
southwest also extending out past the
existing uh rear boundary of the uh of
the dds site
so the main issues for this application
are the principal development so the
impact on the countryside and loss of
agricultural land
the impact on the landscape character
area the economic benefits of the
proposal uh the impact on highways and
transportation and the sustainability of
the site
as well as the other matters the sort of
standard planning matters of impact on
living conditions of the residential
properties which you can obviously see
that a sporadic form of development
along manson road as well as the other
issues of ecology drainage archaeology
etc
so this is an image provided by the
applicant which shows the extent of the
site has superimposed onto a satellite
image just to show you the context so
the
proposed development would would use the
existing access
for um
that's present for uh secure storage
solutions
to access the the site
here
this is the proposed layout of the site
so as mentioned using the existing
access
going in you've got an internal route
and then there are three sort of
sections of the proposal with
landscaping around the outside of the
site as well as a um an area of sort of
designated open space
which is sort of next to where uh the
sort of commercial residential
development is this to the fronting
mansion road in the corner so what i'm
just going to do is go through each
section of the site which relates to the
individual businesses that have been
cited as going on to this site so
starting with uh site one
so
uh this
is a
a commercial development of b2 general
industrial use it's it's 7
220 square meters over two separate
buildings
so you can see here
this has been put forward um as
the operator of ofp timbers
manufacturing timber frames for house
building so that's what it's cited in
the application for um and you can see
obviously there's some mock-ups there
with the logo on the actual premises
itself um the scale of the building
though is obviously going to be fixed in
the appearance of it so this has been
put forward with composite cladding and
a steel roof and all the buildings have
the same materials but with variations
in terms of the color of cladding and
sometimes the cladding is horizontal as
opposed to vertical so the height of
this building
is um it's about 5.5 to the eaves with
the 7.6 to the ridge of this building
then
in terms of the layout of of the
sort of this part of the site you've got
123 spaces car parking spaces serving
this particular unit six lorry spaces
and 46
uh
cycle spaces that are being provided so
from the figures that were submitted
with the application when it was
submitted
in 2020 um it's stated that 75 people
were currently employed at this business
in the in the district and this this
moving would generate an additional 20
employees on top of that now some of
those figures are slightly different to
the ones that have been mentioned but
this is what was put in with the
application
so
just these are the the floor plans just
showing the production area on the
ground floor of building a
with um
this roof plan showing the roof lights
and then you've got building b which is
obviously similar sort of design
for production purposes
uh and then the production area on the
floor plans there
so looking then at site two
so
this is a building totaling
9231 square meters for general
industrial use it doesn't name the the
company that would be looking to go into
this premises but it does mention that
it's a local business
to the district um so the design of the
building is similar to the design of the
other building so we've got the the
composite cladding with the steel roof
but you can see that this building is a
different different sort of shape by
virtue of it's it's long but but quite
thin to reflect a production line for
the general industrial use
so this building is similar in height so
it's 7.9 meters to the ridge with 5.5 to
the eaves
and in this instance um you have
152 car parking spaces 55 cycle spaces
six lorry bays and 10 motorbike spaces
so you can see then a detailed layout
been provided with uh you know with
warehouse storage as well as the actual
production line uh on the right hand
side of the image
and so
using the the statistics provided
this is stated to have um
80 currently employed in 2020 it doesn't
indicate any information of showing any
additional roles to be created through
this um proposal
not saying that they wouldn't be
necessarily and then site three which is
the smallest part of the sites this is
in the
top of the image
so the northern part of the site
so you've got one building here
which has been put forward uh under the
old
b1a use class which is office which is
now used class e g
in the new use classes order and that
totals uh 278 square meters so more of a
sort of office small sort of area
with then an area of about 185
square meters for scaffold racking
because this is proposed to be put
forward for a a scaffolding firm based
in market all access scaffolding um and
so again
similar design to what we've looked at
but with the the horizontal cladding of
a different color
um with uh 6.8 meters to the ridge so a
little bit smaller than the other
buildings and 4.9 meters to the eaves
and so there are 15 parking spaces for
this this proposal
and this is has was put forward
in 2020 as having 60 current employers
with a couple of additional employees
added from the proposal
so and this is just so the uh elevations
of the scaffold rack that's there
um so as you've already heard um
a lot of um considerations been put
forward by the applicant with regards to
the ability for these operators to go on
to the allocated sites in the the local
plan
and their inability to find a suitable
site as put forward so the site isn't
allocated in the local plan for any
development it doesn't fall within any
of the criteria in
policy sp 24 which is the development of
the countryside policy
there is a specific policy
related to new business in the
countryside which is policy at e13 uh
with the local plan which states that
well-designed new development for
economic development purposes for new
businesses will be permitted in
sustainable locations at a scale form
and compatible with their rural
locations so that is a consideration for
this uh this application
um so the report outlines that there has
been information provided a number of
different submissions of information
provided by the applicant
to state the lack of available sites uh
or spaces on the allocated employment
sites as shown on the the slide that you
can see which are the allocated sites in
the local plan to cover the development
of the three businesses
and that has included an assessment of
each of those main sites so it's
included manson business park the
westwood industrial estate the pisces
road industrial estate
um and predominantly they have been
discounted on the basis of the size of
the ask of of what these three
businesses would need
going on to these sites um in particular
and that is prohibitive
so concerns raised in the report from
officers um that the assessment of these
alternative sites is based on all three
businesses being located together rather
than looking at if any of them
individually could go on to any of the
sites that are vacant um
because of that
obviously still feel the policy spo4
which is the strategic policy
about where
economic development all these sorts of
uses should go um and parameters for
economic development um which is
obviously based for the local plan on an
evidence strategy to 2031 should still
be given significant weight uh when
considering this application
notwithstanding that though there is a
consideration here about the economic
benefits of the development which must
be taken into account by members
and obviously in terms of what's been
stated in the application
that that includes 22 new jobs are
stating the application obviously we've
heard from the uh the representative or
separate from locating ken um indicating
there are 18 new jobs to be created
but
primarily the argument has been put
forward this is the retention of jobs
that are already in the district of the
tune of what's stated in the original
application submission of 215.
so the application site um as mentioned
is a mix of grade 1 and grade 2
agricultural land and the applicant has
submitted a
agricultural land assessment
and so great grade 1 and grade 2 is is
excellent to very good best most
versatile agricultural land now
policy e16 uh identifies the test for
the loss of agricultural land uh and
i'll just read from that policy
it states that except on sites allocated
for development by virtue of other
policies in the plan
uh planning provision will not be
granted for significant development
which would result in the irreversible
loss of best and most versatile
agricultural land unless it can be
clearly demonstrated that the benefits
of the proposed development outweigh the
harm resulting from the loss of
agricultural land
there are no other ways no otherwise
suitable sites for poor agricultural
quality that can accommodate the
development and three the development
will not result in the remainder of the
agriculture holding becoming uh not
viable or lead to a likely accumulated
or significant loss of higher quality
agricultural land
well
the argument's been put forward that
it's a sort of
it consolidates the uh existing use
that's there's that's there um with new
businesses and obviously you've heard
from representatives
that the benefits should outweigh the
loss of the agricultural land now
members of attention is drawn to the
application that was submitted quite
quite a number of years ago now and so
it's not relevant in terms of the local
plan as it stands but it was a 2005
application which looked to actually
develop this this site and expanding all
the way to the boundary of this site on
the uh west uh sort of northwest of this
site uh which was put forward at that
time for um for commercial use um and
actually at that point was refused for
the loss of best and most versatile land
um notwithstanding that though again it
still falls to a consideration on the
base of the mppf and the local plan the
the concerns from officers again come
back to that assessment on the base of
three businesses together which are
separate in in user
rather than separately individually
looking at those businesses and whether
they can be accommodated elsewhere
before you end up losing uh irreversibly
the agricultural land um and therefore
we don't consider it has been
demonstrated that these there couldn't
be alternative sites indeed sites of
potentially poor agricultural land
although it is recognized that obviously
thani as everyone knows is abundantly uh
grade one and grade two so it is you
know it's the higher quality
uh and so it's for members to decide
whether or not there is harm as a result
of this development um that um you know
should be taken into account we feel as
officers that that harm from the loss of
agricultural land should be taken into
account in the balance of weighing up
the benefits against the harm
so in terms of the impact on the
countryside this primarily as members
will be aware relates often to a visual
impact so the applicant has submitted a
landscape visual impact assessment with
the application it provided a baseline
assessment of the viewpoints as shown on
this plan you can see here
so just to show you the areas that were
identified by the applicant as having
high sensitivity uh relate to viewpoints
uh
sorry five
six seven and and ten
so the green line that you can see um
coming off of manchester road is a
bridal way
um this um obviously accesses all the
way down to um to other the other bridal
way and then the the road network uh
sort of runs from vincent road across
the fields um as well as obviously
you've got a viewpoint from number seven
here which is a viewpoint from um the
actual sort of corner of vincent road so
just looking at viewpoints uh five and
six
that was submitted in the applicant
submission um so first thing to note
here is that this image was taken in
february 2020 so it's february so it's
winter and there are images though later
on from today that show the amount of
screening that's actually there
right now so
just to go through this though to give
you a context of what's on the dds
demolition site so this is an image just
showing sort of straight on the the
northern elevation of the dds demolition
sites this is the image at the top that
you can see here
the application site spreads sort of
from the right hand side outwards so to
give you an idea of what heights we're
talking about the building that's next
to the sort of in the in the background
where the mouse pointer is
is a is a two-story modular building
that was approved
it was around 2014
which is 5.5 meters high so you can see
there's another warehouse building
that's a bit taller than that so that
gives you a sense of those heights that
i mentioned earlier which in total for
ridge go up to
put the note down go with me up to a
ridge of about 7.9 7.6 but to eaves of
5.5 so it's comparable to those two
buildings that you can see
in terms of the heights of the buildings
that are proposed
so the image on the bottom that you can
see is from further down the bridle way
so further to the west looking back
towards the site uh you can see the
identified application site
is
identified by the arrow
here where my mouse pointer is
so it's an expansion out from that
um
from the the site on the left to the
right so you can you can see the view
there in terms of the landscape
character area
in terms of this image this is the
further back image so we're now um going
further to the north from from number 10
so i'll just go back just to show you
where you're looking from so number 10
so the top of your map there
looking back towards the site so you can
see again the the dds demolition site in
the in the distance you've got an
another outcrop site on manston road
and that the applicant has put forward
the extent of the application site here
um showing the expansion point uh of
across the field to the point that's
dotted on the right hand side
so um as mentioned the landscape visual
impact assessment has indicated that
there is the need for mitigation to
mitigate the impact of developing the
site again just to remind you of the
layout and you have a smaller building
that's in the sort of very northern
point of the site and then you have
the the longer building uh serving the
what was before the sort of unit two
um which has um obviously the eaves of
5.5 and ridge of 7.9 so what's being
proposed is a landscape buffer around
the edge of the site the planting mixes
in the bottom left of the image here
this this mix
includes um a number of species which
could grow in maturity to in some
instances between
actually 20 and 40 meters high
not that that's the intention i think to
go to 40 meters but the strategy states
that in 10 years coverage would very
clearly be found to
alleviate the impact of any um visual
incursion into the countryside
a bit albert by um you know sort of
covering it with trees um out on the
site so
going through the photos from today
we're just going to go along the the
track from the the corner of
vincent road so you can see this is the
image of the dds site from earlier today
so you can now see you can see
where hopefully the mouse pointer is
down here the edge of that building that
we saw that's the 5.5 meter high
building you can see the landscaping is
is going a little bit above that so sort
of covering that's the established
landscaping along there um screening the
existing buildings on the dds demolition
site from this particular viewpoint so
going along the bridal way so this is
what you're looking at for the bridal
way so you've got an access that serves
a couple of properties
off off the bridleway but then you're
going on to a brighter way that runs
along the field
so this is a view showing the bridal way
at the bottom of the image running along
you can see dds demolition
here in this area on the left hand side
so you can see that when you're moving
along this you can see a further angle
of the site in question so the views
from manson road are present but are
limited to the extent that you could see
here
this is just standing literally just off
manson road so there would be a further
incursion into the countryside
but the depth of the site obviously
isn't really at this point the main
sensitivity view is from the bridle way
itself as you travel through along the
bridle way from
either west to east or east to west
so
this is the end of the dds simulation
site with the landscaping and so we're
extending to the right-hand side of this
you can see the edge of the child's
river site behind there is a slight
change in the land level from the bridle
way slightly slightly up but it's a
generally flat landscape
this is just showing the bridal way just
so you can see what sort of is is
he's a well-worn root
um and then
this image and you can see there's a
there's a digger on top of a mound at
the back of in fact back of the site
that's proposed to be developed so sort
of around this area
and then expanding out so
to give you an idea this is a mast
that's on the
charles river site which is here
the development runs uh up to
the point of the edge of the end of the
charles river site along the back so
effectively you're squaring off
uh in this area here so um effectively
the the view that we were just looking
at um would include the incursion across
here with the buildings and landscaping
now the landscape character area is the
manson chalk plateau which is
characterized as a generally flat or
generally undulating landscape with
extensive uh unenclosed fields under
intensive agricult arable cultivation
often um
and but it does acknowledge that it's an
open landscape which is fragmented by
large-scale development obviously you've
got manson airport you've got charles
river so there are developments
that are around there
however it is considered by officers
that
this would result in harm to the
countryside by virtue of removing what
is a flat and open landscape from the
viewpoints predominantly from the bridal
way
even if you are screening it with
landscaping one it's it's obviously a
long-term a medium-term impact um
because obviously the nature of the
landscape you're having to take
but then you are obviously moving and
creating landscaping where previously
there there wasn't any so we do feel
that there is harm to the landscape
character that members should consider
in the balance of the application
and this is just a view just looking
from the brighter way back towards the
back of the dds demolition side back to
the mansion road so you can again see
the extent of the existing site and it
would push further to the right hand
side
so in terms of highways
impact um
the
application site as mentioned earlier
includes um car parking which is
tailored specifically for the the needs
of the individual businesses that have
been put forward
um so it provides over the amount of car
parking as we understand from highways
required for the floor space of
commercial development but it's under
the maximum parking standards there are
maximum parking standards it is under
that um and um it's acknowledged that
during the course of the application it
was a concern that was raised by uh
highways about the extent of car parking
the amount of car parking has been
reduced during the course of the
application uh from 338 to 290 spaces
proposed
now
as mentioned on a highway capacity point
um the proposal is to use the existing
site access
um the visibility you apologize you
might not be able to actually see it but
it's a dotted line and you can see that
there's some text here um has just made
sure with some tracking plans provided
that actually this existing access
is suitable to use for the number of
businesses that are going in that would
be accessing via this um no objection
has been raised by highways on the use
this access so this is just one image
showing one way so we're looking towards
the the north
and then this is a view uh looking
towards the south so you can see it so
it's a wide
bell mouth access
that provides sufficient for vehicles to
um to pass
so in terms of
the capacity of highways
there has been a submission
that um that has put forward for um
from highways uh about the impact on
spitfire junction so
the spitfire junction has members will
be aware he's a junction that is at
capacity this is identified through the
local plan in the modeling of all the
strategic allocations and all of the
modeling for the local plan it shows
that spitfire junction is at capacity
and any increase in traffic throughput
there of any substantial nature would
cause further congestion and potential
safety issues now the applicant has
worked with highways
looking at the scheme
that's shown in this image here
what this proposes um and just to come
back on one point the uh this has
received a contribution already from the
minster housing site which was secured
by by members of the committee
um
this is to propose that effectively you
your signalize this junction and you'd
realign it so that you end up getting um
a
uh i think it's best to explain it by
showing you the image uh next but if you
if you're coming uh down from margate
there is a left hand turn lane that
effectively runs on the existing course
of the junction uh but with some of the
the highway uh sort of it's not quite
verge it's uh it's this area here where
the road sign is effectively this area
would be lost this hard surfaced area to
basically create it so that from this
view which is a
elevated view from street view so that
cars effectively could move from
spitfire away and go straight over the
junction after the signalized junction
is gone so it wouldn't result in the
loss of these trees but it just results
in the loss of this area here uh with
the fact that you would have to
basically turn right around in the new
alignment and this is something that
highways have been working on for a
while um
and the applicant has stated a
willingness to pay the required highways
contribution towards the work now to
clarify the point that that's been made
earlier um and it's it is identified in
the report
um because the recommendation which i've
still come on to is for refusal and that
we don't have a legal agreement at this
point in time to secure the contribution
towards this there is a technical reason
for refusal which is reason for refusal
for
um which simply sort of identifies the
fact that we don't have an obligation to
secure the contribution for these works
but the applicants stated they're
willing to to pay it so if the other
issues are resolved or members feel that
it is an approval this is an issue that
could be dealt with via a legal
agreement
in addition to that
concern's been raised by highways about
the need for
restrictions on vincent road to do with
hdv movements there is a
sign that's up on vincent road which is
a sort of an advisory sign saying no
htvs but it's actually to get um through
a section uh 278 agreement under the
highway act effectively a prohibition on
um hdvs using vincent road because from
the traffic capacity and the studies
that have been done the development
could result in hdbs using vincent road
to sort of cut across the fields again
depending on when spitfire junction
works take place
again that is an issue that would be
overcome by a legal agreement so that is
again why that reason is a technical
reason for refusal
so in terms of the sustainability of the
site um
the
sorry let me just shift over to my notes
um the
officers have raised concerns about the
sustainability of the site due to its
location um now it's identified by the
applicant that obviously the site um is
sort of surrounded by you know other
developments that are predominantly car
reliant
however officers are concerned there is
no footwear linking this site with
the
public transport links
the closest of which is a bus stop at
spitfire way
and obviously with
a prohibitive distance to walk to the
nearest station which i think once built
would probably be the parkway i'd
imagine but at the moment it's margate
now
it's you know understood that um it's
the applicants submitted a travel plan
and that predominantly looks to
encourage cycling car sharing as
mentioned a crew bus that could pick
people up a number of people up
and that travel plan includes specific
targets uh to try and um get people to
you know car share and
and as well as using the crew bus or
indeed um increasing the number of the
employees that would cycle to the site
as well as electric vehicle charging
points and those targets uh would
actually also be looked at by a
coordinator that would be
appointed through the the travel plan
and
obviously there are concerned about the
fact that this is you know it's a 60
mile an hour road is entirely um unsafe
for pedestrians to use and therefore the
development is totally reliant really on
on private vehicle
um and we've already mentioned the
policy e13 which is a you know a policy
about new development in the countryside
new business of the country when it's a
sustainable form of development um and
it sort of goes hand in hand with a
concern about the the fact that this
isn't a strategic um
employment development linked through
the local plan which could facilitate
certain requirements through for example
strategic infrastructure improvements um
on balance therefore from from outside
of things we do consider it's an
unsustainable form of development on on
transportation by virtue of that lack of
footwear and that reliance on private
vehicle
as well and it's considered that that
harm should again go into the the
balance of the application
so
apologies members i will wrap up this is
sorry this is just a a view of manston
road just showing um going to the south
of the site so you can see it's a 60
mile an hour road in it it's got the
highway verge here but but no pedestrian
footwear
um so in terms of the other matters the
um
report goes through the other
considerations um including um the
applicant has looked at noise monitoring
has been submitted to
the council's environmental health team
and environment i think agree with the
conclusions of noise monitoring you can
see just here the dots here where noise
monitoring took place
um and with sensitive receptors
identified you've got residential
properties on manson road
and environmental agreed with the
conclusions but they require conditions
in relation to a three-meter high
acoustic fence and various different
restrictions on different units delivery
times and the proposal generally would
be operating from 6am to 10pm but there
would need to be restrictions on
deliveries sort of
outside of these times um from
archaeology purposes uh the desk-based
assessment has been carried out and the
baseline has been accepted by kcc uh but
any approval would require a program of
works with the requirement of of likely
geophysical surveys and and trial
trenching as required with safeguarding
conditions required
in that instance
in terms of ecology
survey work has been carried out and
there are recommendations in that server
work for enhancements um that has been
looked at by kcc biodiversity uh they do
consider that
with the use of the native species for
planting
that it would be acceptable but they
would require more of a detailed plan to
provide uh specific details including um
matters to the roots for hedgehogs as
well as the exact planting next to
hedgerows to create the required routes
and enhancement to biodiversity
other matters including air quality
contamination and drainage um have all
been looked at by consultees and are
considered that with conditions would be
acceptable
for drainage and this is a plan just
showing um the extent of the permeable
surfaces which are in um
in red
there is you know proposed to have um
you know drainage basin and and pond
obviously we are in an area that's quite
important to ensure that surface water
drainage is treated correctly and
therefore there are it would be a
grampian condition requirement for a
sustainable drainage scheme to be
submitted which would test matters such
as the infiltration rate that's been put
forward within the drainage scheme
to to cover that point
so
overall um the case for members is to
balance the economic benefits of the
development um
against the identified harms from
officers it is considered that in
office's view that the benefits are
outweighed by the impact on the
countryside the loss of agricultural
land and the the particular highway
safety uh concerns and location concerns
and therefore there are four reasons for
a refusal identified uh in the
application and it's recommended to
refuse by officers thank you council
thomas
uh thank you ian i move the officer's
recommendation
is adopted to the vice chair please
second oh second nature
thank you councilman cook members
council ghana
thank you and thank you
ian very thorough
presentation
um i do have just uh
to start with i've got a question really
you about the
the land that this site sits on i mean
if you've you've mentioned it's a great
one and two agricultural land and we
also mentioned that it is land that is
owned by the applicant
i believe
um
that's just the picture you've got up
there i wanted to see
um so this is part of a much larger
piece of agricultural land is that all
owned by the
by the applicant
um and also i've just followed from that
of it being agricultural land is it
is it being farmed at the moment it will
will it is there
you know what crops are being grown on
there at the moment
thanks
um i i the the rest of that land that
you can probably see from identified is
within the blue line plan so it is owned
by the applicant i i can't i can't
comment on on exactly the specifics i
must admit i'd have to go and check the
the agricultural report in terms of
whether or not it's used i mean it's
classed as through the report that has
submitted
um
agricultural
best and most versatile agricultural
land um
apologies for my ignorance i don't know
if you will be able to identify uh by
virtue of that
did you want to come back to council
um
not at the moment no i i can see
i just wanted to understand yes it's all
very well being labeled as agricultural
land and i can see that it it is but it
isn't if it's isn't being used currently
as agricultural land if the applicant is
is leaving it fallow i think that's the
correct farming term
um i just wanted to understand that that
was
thank you council heart
thank you chair i'm
guessing looking at the filters it's
either wheat or barley one of the two
but you can't quite tell it's too far
away um i've got a few things to say
about this um as you know i'm not quite
most time
i
i do think that we do need to have more
businesses in the countryside for people
to work and to be fair to
the
applicant
a farmer could just put up
buildings or sheds if you want to call
them the size of those anyway and there
couldn't really be much that the council
could do
if it was farmland anyway whether they
were just for storage or whatever so i'd
like that cleared up um
and i do think the economic benefits of
this are very good and i do know the
site to a degree because obviously we
all drive down that road occasionally or
if we don't live in burst until we drive
that way um and it has got a good sight
line there's not many business houses
really around that's going to be
affected in my mind um and also you know
yeah i understand that the council's
comment with or the officer's comment
with regards to the fact there's no
payment there isn't a payment um there's
no psychopath there isn't a psychopath
or money cycle piles in the than anyway
um there are pavements obviously but
then nobody wants an industrial estate
in the middle of um town so you know
there are always going to be objections
to that and you know you allow planet
earth to put a huge building up and
people walk down a country lane that's
60 mile an hour carrying boxes of fruit
and i've seen them many of the time
because my garage my car mechanics that
way and that they even have to cross
over the authentic way the dual carriage
park just to get a pass to get home so i
i think the argument is there's no
payments it is a is a nonsense really um
with regards to what what you want to do
and i just think we've we've got to be
educated about this because we we are
keeping a keep agree
agreeing that we're going to allow
houses um
to be built on land but people have got
to have a job to go to to have a house
or somewhere to live and if you haven't
got the jobs then we can't have the
houses and to be fair to the council
unfair to the council i think
you put a very negative
spin on this
application compared to if it was houses
that you want to be built on that area
and i think that was a a very disjustice
to the applicant really because i i
think it was a very negative proposal
and i think that we should be looking at
these in a positive attitude um okay
we're gonna lose a bit of
agricultural land and i would assume
that the person who owns the land will
actually reap the crop or take the crop
in before they actually destroy it um
but i i just think we've got to be a
little bit more sensible about all this
stuff and and to refuse i think he's
just totally wrong thank you chad
uh thank you council heart i'm going to
bring ian back on a comment you made
there it's just to come back on the farm
pd point um yet there are provisions
when agriculture holdings are certain
size that allow for buildings to be
built so in terms of that particular
point then technically there is the
ability to have buildings of a certain
scale which could result in a landscape
visual impact in in in itself
um so that is something that you know
that that's to consider i mean i do
think that
you know we're obviously not looking at
a proposal for housing but i would i
would argue that
the sustainability of the location
is something that is considered when it
comes to
residential development and obviously
members more recently have been looking
at applications where actually the sites
have been allocated for residential
development in the local plan and when
they're not allocated one of the main
types of applications that come forward
are ones on the edge of the urban
confines now obviously
whilst there is sporadic development
around here
this is
is nowhere near the urban confines and
the aim obviously of housing development
is to try and make it as sustainable as
possible by putting it as close as
possible to transport links you know and
next to the urban confines if the
landscape visual impact is acceptable on
the countryside and obviously that's why
we've raised a concern in this instance
um
and you know i i accept your point of
concern that it's we're not sort of
putting forward the benefits in a
stronger way but i think we have
identified that there are obviously
economic developments sorry economic
benefits that members should consider
but the office of view is that they're
outweighed by the harm thank you chair
uh
yes i'll let you come back council heart
thank you
thank you and that's very fair comment
um uh return to that and i mean to be
you as we all know we've all used the
spitfire junction if if this applicant
is prepared to sort that out then thank
god for them because it is the most you
know i've had my car smack there it's
the most dangerous junction turning
right out there and we've all agreed the
um other end of the road of vanstone
road to be done for houses and that is
all going to be sorted out as well so
all the junctions down that end are
going to be sorted as well so it's going
to be a nice place to have a
a commercial development realistically
and it is the perfect spot i think
personally
uh thank you councillor tesco uh thank
you chair uh first of all can i get a
clarification please um ian from
yourself
um you said that uh ofp for example are
in the district
uh
last time i looked ofp or in sandwich
which i believe is in dover district can
you confirm that please um i would need
can i come back to you on that just
because if it's the case that they're
not in the district then technically i
can clarify the number of jobs that
would technically be in the district by
virtue of this proposal but i will just
double check that that's okay
okay
just just just to carry on then uh chair
thank you i agree with councillor hart
on on his highways um
comments and and and yeah
basically people are going to that sort
of uh
industry and that go in a car or a van
mini bus
whatever but they very rarely walk to
these places um i've never seen it but
most industrial units are outside town
people have arrangements to get there is
usually by vehicle so i'm not really
worried about the highways
um
if i'm correct in what i'm saying about
the ofp for example which i believe is
in sandwich uh it is outside our
district in which case it will be
bringing uh nearly 200 jobs to the area
and not 20. thank you
thank you counselor
i can bring back ian on what you've
brought up there
thank you yes i can yeah i can confirm
you're quite right councillor rozeki
it's um that they're based on two sites
at the moment outside the district uh so
just to confirm that's site one where it
states that 75 people
are currently employed there in 2020
with 20 additional so technically then
that's i suppose on those figures that's
95 jobs coming into the district uh with
the others being the retained jobs as
stated
thank you
thank you councillor alban
yeah thank you oh
you counter alban
just a moment counselor
i can dress up
you don't need to no uh yeah thank you
chair um
i think the way that this discussion is
going i think we're all
some of us
are like-minded
in relation to this development um
having given duken consideration to to
the to the long
proposal that ian has put put forward um
of course his uh
his
talk about the the application the app
the application because he's refused it
he would um
it would be in a negative wouldn't it
um
but um
i i think you know it the
no
industrial unit is pretty
yeah it doesn't where it doesn't matter
where it's located
um
there's plenty of other agricultural
grade one
or two agricultural land
attached to this
proposed development
we definitely need the jobs and i i do
go along with the council of hearts view
in in relation to
the junction because we all know that
that needs to be done and if they're
going to pay for it then then
great
um i would just i would just make a
point in
reading some of the consultations one of
which ian hasn't mentioned
which was from natural england
of which they have no objection based on
the plans submitted natural england
considered that the proposed development
will not have significant adverse
impacts on the statutory protected
nature conservation sites i i mean i
think that was that's a big
issue with that so um
for me chair i
i can't go along with the officer's
recommendation thank you chair
uh thank you uh council clinton
haven't forgotten your counseling
you'll get there
thank you um i just have a couple of
questions really
one is to do with some reassurance that
the parking level um will be adequate
because as has already been indicated um
it's unlikely that people are going to
be walking to this site
and i'm i'm trying to remember what what
was i've seen already but uh i did hear
that the parking had been reduced
um
and whether or not there's
alternative uh
is it just cars or are there other forms
of transport that are deemed likely to
be used i don't know what the existing
um
staffing are using
and the other
my second
thought is that we're covering open land
with buildings and concrete um what
provision is there and what thought has
been given to um rainwater drainage
because of the loss of
of that
um by putting concrete down yeah we
might be in the report but i can't
remember it
um so to
just come back in terms of car parking
so
the amount of car parking that it's been
reduced to is considered to be
appropriate for the number so for the
sort of the way that highways calculate
is often on the floor space creates a
certain number of employees but also the
applicant has submitted information
about the sort of general number of
employees that this this results in
and therefore the level of parking is
considered to be
um sufficient for what's being proposed
um in terms of
provision for or other
vehicles as i mentioned there are
a
substantial amount of cycle parking with
the travel plan submitted by the
applicant uh aiming to try and increase
the amount of of cycling uh with a
target of somewhere increasing the
amount of cycling by three percent there
is some information that's been provided
by the applicant which looked at
the units of one the ofp
and all access in terms of
the
percentage of um how people actually got
to their existing sites um and
predominantly that was via cars sort of
76 percent sorry 72 percent of of for
unit 1's workers
and 50
um well and 100 in fact for for unit
three which is the uh all-access site
that's in
hearts down i'm going to just say hearts
down and look at council roseanne hope
he doesn't correct me uh there
for all access um
the the [ __ ] the travel plan is is key
though and i think obviously i can
understand that members are
you know moving to to a point of of
considering this to be acceptable
because
the travel plan is only as good as the
monitoring that occurs to ensure it's
actually occurring and it's something
that um would certainly need to be an
obligation within the 106 agreement to
have a contribution towards the highways
uh
officer that looks at all the travel
plans and actually monitors actually
what they're doing on whether or not
they're actually according with their
travel plans to try and increase um as
much as possible other modes of
transportation but obviously officers
concern is that none of that will
involve walking to the site at all
and therefore none of it's going to link
to the existing bus network either so
you are limited in terms of where your
gains will come in terms of um employees
coming to this site
oh and drainage um
so if i just quickly pop back to the
image that i showed at the end
in terms of
sorry
in terms of the the drainage scheme so
what we have is a sort of strategy with
a plan that shows that um
that that it's likely that the drainage
can be dealt with in terms of rain water
on the site through uh infiltration uh
via sort of basins and storage
underneath the permanent paving however
we do need more detail so that's why um
ken as the kcc is the lead highway sorry
the local lead flood authority
have required a grampian condition which
would require very detailed drainage
scheme to come in predominantly that's
about the infiltration rate and how much
it can actually drain into the various
sources so
but we don't consider it to be a problem
there will be a technical solution to
overcome so it wouldn't form a reason
for refusal on that basis
thank you castlewing thank you chair i
mean i don't think any of us is really
comfortable about building on
our farmland a very rich farmland so
we we stuck between a rock and a hard
place but i do find it quite strange and
i agree with councillor hart that we sit
here
seems month after month approving big
big residential builds on agricultural
land and now we've got a commercial
build that that we've been asked to
refuse
i do know the road quite well because i
use the the boarding house and it is a
bad road there's no no question it's a
bad road but i also knew that know the
dds site quite well and it it's a very
tidy and a very clean site so i think if
if the developers are going to
base their standards on the dds site
then then i think it will probably be a
good development i have noted that
southern water have concerns over
possible pollution and again i will
quote the the ex-ceo of southern water
saying we're very
water stretched in this area
so it's good to see that southern water
have put in a range of things that have
to be done and also following on kcc
obviously want more information relating
to drainage
so i i think i'm of a mind to support
this application on the understanding
that the developer honors everything in
it that is in the plan and and looks to
to make this as higher quality
development as possible going back to
walking to the site being able to walk
to the site i've yet to find a direct
walk to parkway station from the far end
of ramsgate so we approved that without
actually considering whether anybody
could walk or cycle there directly and
they can't
uh thank you for that counselling cancer
payment
thank you chair um firstly
i disagree that the um report was
negative to be honest i had to look back
to check the recommendation i think it
was very fair i think we were able to
see
both aspects of
the the heart the possible
possible harm and the benefits but
i do feel that the in this case the
economic benefits do outweigh harm to
the countryside
i think our local area for our local
area should thrive
we need to accommodate businesses and to
provide employment
it is a fragmented landscape i
particularly
approve of the landscape the landscape
buffer that's being supplied
and as other members have said the
improvement to the spitfire junction if
it's
uh agreed
i think would be excellent
so um and also the implementation of the
travel plan so i i feel that i would
like to support this application thank
you
uh thank you councillor rayford
councillor heart toughly comes that's a
quick one chair um can we say to the
applicant if they wish and can we agree
as well if they want to put solar panels
on the roof to get some natural
electricity it doesn't have to come back
to planning um because obviously it's a
big area which is covered and that would
be quite nice if they could actually do
that we can't force them obviously but
bring it back to play if they want to do
that it'd be a bit silly really
being a comeback uh there are permitted
development rights for certain
commercial promises to have solar panels
i believe one of them may actually
propose solar panels within their
proposal so your wishes
granted
council ghana thank you yeah i just
wanted to um
come to the defense of the officer's
recommendation on this one um
one of my main concern
on
on this with this application like on a
lot of others whether it's land
designated in the local plan or isn't
land designated in the local plan is the
continual loss of prime agricultural
land in phthalo
and we're we're losing we're losing too
much and with the current world
situation we know we're going to need to
hold on to as much as we can and we can
know we're going to need to grow our own
in this country and we can't rely on
imports of of um agricultural produce so
i do think we
we need to consider that a lot more
carefully thank you
thank you council ghana and take your
point there
thank you members i think you've had a
good report and um i think a fair debate
as well
so i have to put this to you which is um
the motion is for officers
recommendation which is to refuse this
application
can i have a show of hands who are in
favor of refusal
one
two
those against
abstentions
right that motion has been lost so if
you could bear with me one moment please
i will come back straight to mr
livingston um so it's obviously a very
clear members view on this uh
application um there are particular
requirements for approving this
development um primarily this relates to
a lot of the console t comments that
have come in which have requested
various safeguarding conditions
obviously i've understood that the main
driver for
the outweighing process of the various
identified harms is about the economic
benefits and so
my recommendation to you now following
the debate
would be um obviously if a member was to
move a motion that would approve the
application
um as the application by virtue of the
economic benefits uh from the proposal
on the application applicant's
submission outweighs the identified harm
subject to appropriate safeguarding
conditions
and the receipt of a legal agreement
securing contributions towards off-site
highway improvements
at spitfire junction vincent road and
travel plan monitoring uh and usually we
would require that within six months so
that's to try and make sure no one's
dragging their heels on any side of
things
and if it did go over six months we'd
have to bring it back to members uh
thank you for that ian well you've heard
what ian said there i'd like a proposal
i'll propose that
chancellor heart i believe his hand up
first i won't go into arguments
and i won't ask you to repeat what mr
livingston said because i know you won't
be able to remember it nor can i
um
secondly by councillorski
you've heard the new motion those in
favor
anybody against
abstentions
that has been carried thank you members
thank you
i just let members
leave
okay members moving on to agenda item 5b
an application for deferral of the
former british gas site on north dam
road
in broad stairs now i have a
note here which i would like
to listen to please
if you would note that miss culligan
which who is the director of law and
democracy authentic council has
requested that for the purposes of
transparency
if he noted that mr goddard who is
speaking on this application as a local
planning consultant is her husband
this has been recorded as an officer
register
of interest
which i think is very fair and thank you
for that
speaking in favor of the application um
mr goddard please you have three minutes
thank you chair thank you members uh the
applicants have a very long history in
saint peter's they denoted land for the
cemetery and for mock its wood and a
village green
they also enabled the co-op the health
center and retirement housing to be
built at hopeful avenue
with this application scheme they
continue that legacy by including much
needed and policy compliant thirty
percent affordable housing more than two
acres of compensatory land to deliver
biodiversity net gain
around a hundred
sorry i'm exaggerating around 1 million
of section 106 contributions
and the costly additional remediation of
this contaminated site
the site has a lawful use for commercial
storage and that's a use which would
generate substantial heavy goods vehicle
movements which would be
damaging to the highway network and
would be unsightly site was previously
allocated in the draft local plan for
housing all the proposed housing would
be within the identified built confines
in the local plan and none is within the
green wedge or on agricultural land
the land has already been partially
decontaminated for its use as commercial
storage
and it will be further decontaminated to
a condition which is suitable for
housing
all the trees identified by the
council's tree officer as important have
been retained additional trees will be
planted and a five metre landscape
buffer outside domestic gardens will be
created around the edge of the built
development
beyond this is a 2.2 acre area of
undeveloped compensatory land which will
contain ponds and low-level planting to
attract wildlife and enhance
biodiversity
some objectives have said that this is
cramped development however your local
plan applies a notional density of 12
dwellings per acre and this scheme is 11
per acre and incorporates a play area
and a spacious layout
the scheme before you has been subject
to extensive consideration by your
officers and all the statutory
consultees including kent highways
none object to the grant of planning
permission
overall the proposals comply with
national and local policies by taking a
contaminated brownfield site within the
built confines in a sustainable location
with a lawful use for commercial storage
further remediating the land and
provided much needed
housing
30 of which would be affordable
and in addition we're providing a full
set
of these section 106 contributions
amount amounting to around 1 million
pounds
the application is fully supported by
your officers
and i ask members of this planning
committee to share your officers
conclusions that this proposal has
significant benefits
which outweigh any extremely limited
environmental harm thank you chair
thank you very much schmidt scott
speaking
with an objection
is miss sutton if you're there please we
have three minutes
thank you
well i'm the chair of friends of markets
wood which is a community woodland
adjacent to the gas works mentioned in
this planning application managed by
broadstairs peters town council and by
local volunteers i attended the last
appeal hearing where this was refused
i wish to object to the above
application on many grounds it's likely
to lead to erosion of our much needed
green wedge and it's not designated to
propose housing in the neighborhood plan
at present
overbuilding specifically in saint
peter's where the these gas works are
located there's a small hump bridge over
a railway line next to the site the
bridge can only take one car
either way and has a separate small lane
for pedestrians
parts of saint peter's lie within the
conservation area which is already
congested along vicarage street there
are two areas which are only one way and
with calming traffic calming some of the
pavements are only wide enough to allow
one pedestrian
the planned housing will only add much
more congestion and lead if not to a
complete shutdown frequent gridlock it
is likely that people will want to go
through saint peters to broadstairs or
westwood cross for their shopping or to
the beach
the b2053 is also congested and subject
to traffic calming
previous applications to build on the
farmland between the gas works
mucketswood and the a-255 have been
rejected on appeal by central government
but i worry that this if this planning
application is granted it may lead to a
resuscitation
of the previous applications in the
future
at the appeal decision regarding the
previous planning application
that i can give you the number but the
inspector wrote in section 18 that he
had heard that the site that is the gas
works had been remediated to a level so
that can be used for storage in this
respect the evidence before me suggests
that the site has a realistic existing
use for storage which a landowner could
implement and moreover later on in the
appeal he says in section 21 that the
appeal proposal would be contrary to the
aims of policy cc5
and that there is a lack of essential
need for the development to be located
there i do not find that there is an
overriding need to locate housing in
this part of the countryside at the
current time
so as permission was not granted at the
appeal for the adjacent field to be
developed the appellant's argument then
that the development of the gas works
would only be viable if the permission
for the adjacent field was granted makes
a nonsense of this planning application
at present the gas works cannot be built
on for residential application with
development without vast sums of money
being spent to further decontaminate
thus to recoup these sums of money and
make a profit the proposed development
would need to build houses too expensive
to be considered for social housing or
they would need to be crammed in
there are insufficient amenities let
alone water in thailand to cater for the
already high number of housing
developments in the area and if this
application goes ahead it will increase
footfall through mock its wood threaten
its very existence
as the foot pass through act as
shortcuts away from the congestion
the wood itself is home to many bird
species trees and other plants and fungi
and is an important popular local
amenity the appellant should apply for
government funding to rewild plant trees
and thus improve the biodiversity and
create a green corridor for nature
thank you uh thank you mr sutton uh i
asked the planning officer to outline
the report which i think is emma
thank you chairman this is the
application site outlined in red here so
on the right hand side of the screen is
north down road and you can see the
railway running along the northeastern
side of the site and to the west of the
site and south of the site is open
countryside
this is an aerial view of the site so
the site boundary
um of the um housing development runs
along this
line here so you can see there's a
existing line of trees that run along
the boundary of the site again you can
see the
railway to the north and above that is
an employment site with commercial units
to the east of the site you can see our
existing residential properties at front
north down road and to the right hand
side here you can see is mock its wood
so this is a further view every view
looking towards the application site so
again the application site runs along
this boundary here
and then a further view again looking
towards the application site which is in
this location here so this all of this
area here is open countryside and green
wedge
and then this is just looking from north
down road towards the site so you can
see the application site again is here
so you can see within the site is
previously developed land there's quite
a few areas of hard surfacing within the
site
and the photos i show you later would
actually be more in this area here
because we can easily get access to this
space but there's a substation in this
location
and lots of fencing within this location
as well
and then again a further view looking at
towards the site and it's in in the
context of the countryside
so and the photos i'm now going to show
you will start at this point here within
north down road looking towards the
access will go into the site and then
i'll show you around the boundaries
boundary of the site so this is the
existing access into the site from north
down road so the bridge is off to the
right hand side and you can see
residential properties on the left hand
side here
then as you go into the site you can see
the the hard surface in the road leading
into the sites and then on the right
hand side here is the existing
substation with palisade fencing around
it
and again here you can see the
substation and now this is inside the
site and so this is now looking towards
the southern boundary
and then moving along you can see the
existing trees along the site so one of
the concerns raised was lots of trees
none of these trees are protected i've
been on site with the tree officer we've
had a look at the trees none of the
trees are considered to be worthy of a
tree protection
tree preservation order
um but you'll see later on that we are
seeking to retain these trees as a
screen along the boundary
so again this is now looking towards
the further towards the west of the site
you can see again the existing trees
along here and
that's the far west of the site so the
railway is off to the right hand side
here and this is the commercial
development
and then now looking towards the north
with again the railway behind so this is
probably one of the best
trees on the site
and then this is now looking further to
the east so again all these trees along
the boundary here the majority of these
are being retained so the only trees
really looking to be removed are in the
location of
the access
and then this is again standing in the
center of the site looking off to the
east
so this is now back in north down road
and this is the existing
bridge that runs over the railway and
you can see it's quite narrow and there
are currently um some
concerns with lack of visibility as you
go across the bridge
and this is standing on the bridge
looking towards the application site
which is on the left-hand side so these
were
the trees that you could see from within
the site along the boundary so some of
these are actually on the highway on the
railway verge and then there's some
additional trees on the other side of
this actually within the application
site
this is within north down roads just so
you can see the the general carrots of
the area so there's a range of style of
um dwellings within the area there's as
you can see terrace units and detached
units mainly on this side of the road on
the right hand side is mainly a row of
semi detached units
all of them are two story in height
this is now um from towards the
east of the site looking towards the
site so the application site is this
location here so this is the existing
boundary of the site with the row of
trees
and then again just you see this is a
boundary running here and then it tucks
in here and then again this is the
corner of the application site
and this is the um neighboring
properties that are to the east to the
site
so this was the original plan that was
submitted as part of the application
this was for 60 units it's an outline
form the proposal is considering the
access into the site and the proposed
layout
you can see that there was a a range of
unit types within
the development so you can see there's a
mix of terrorist and and semi-detached
units
you can see the location of the play
area which was in this far northern
corner
um along the boundary these trees were
looking to be retained but you can see
that the trees were located within the
gardens of the properties so there was
concern that if this was to
be allowed that in the future because
they're not protected there would be the
potential for these trees to be failed
and there was concern as well that in
terms of the views of the into the site
from the green wedge that in terms of
the the layout that was proposed it was
quite
um sort of a
heavy form of development with limited
spaces between the units so from the
views you see into the site it would
appear quite
over developed potentially
um so we did look to amend this to turn
the units around um and to relocate the
play area and to improve tree planting
so this is now the current proposal
that's before members
tonight so you can see here these are
the units on the western side they've
been reorientated so that there's lots
of space in between the units which will
allow for um views through between the
between the buildings
the play space has been relocated into
this far southern corner which is
improves access into the site and would
actually improve
the the access to the surrounding
community
in terms of the tree
screening the
trees along here so the green trees are
the retained existing trees and then the
black outlines are the proposed trees so
we're actually looking to create a
buffer strip along here that would be
which would fall outside any of the
cursed edges of the properties and
there's a condition that would seek to
retain this as a buffer strip as part of
future reserve matters application and
long term as an immunity strip which
would allow for the trees to be retained
into the future even though they do not
have the preservation order on them
you can see that buffer strip extends
right down on the the boundary of the
site right to the far southern corner
and actually extends around the play
space as well so we'll actually create
quite
a softening of the boundary into the
site
this area on the left-hand side here is
um what's um annotated on the plan as
the compensatory land
so this area that's
is actually within the green wedge so
the green wedge boundary
is this line here so the site itself is
actually within the urban confines but
this area here on the left hand side is
in the green wedge
this
area of land is proposed for low level
planting and for the drainage to serve
the development
and so the reason for this is that
within the site itself there's quite a
high level of contamination um whilst
that currently has been remediated to
serve the open storage use the site it
needs further remediation for the
proposed residential use
and because of the contaminational site
there's concerns that there's not it's
not possible to have um a sustainable
urban drainage system within the site
and they're actually this actually needs
to be off-site where there's no
contamination and investigation works
have taken place that have shown that
there's limited contamination in this
area here and so
um kcc studs have agreed that this is an
appropriate solution for the drainage so
whilst this the use of this land will
result in some loss of open countryside
in terms of the impact on the green
wedge and the landscape character area
it will still remain open in appearance
with the low level planting so there
won't be any tree planting within the
site the tree planting is solely along
the actual boundary of the site and this
will remain as open space so the actual
use of this land for the planting and
the attenuation pond would actually have
limited impact on the green wedge and
landscape character area
so just to show you again in the context
in terms of the aerial
this again is the existing boundary of
the site this area here would be the
area of of agricultural land that would
be used for drainage and for um
the low level planting
at this point i'll just give you a bit
of history on the site and what happened
with the previous application so a
previous application was submitted which
included this area of land here this
open countryside site here which did
fall within the green wedge
we refused this application on the
impact it had on the green wedge because
of long views into the the space the
loss of openness
and this was went to appeal and won this
appeal
so the the reason for that piece of land
being used as part of the development
was argued by the agent as being that
this piece of land was needed in order
to make the whole site viable at this
point in time this site was allocated in
the draft local plan for housing
so we were looking for that site to come
forward for housing but we were advised
by the agent that it could only be
viable if this area of land was also
developed as part of the scheme
obviously we did not consider that to be
acceptable which is why it was refused
and following the appeal decision this
area of land um the application site has
been taken out as a housing allocation
so it's now no longer allocated within
the sanic local plan so it has a lawful
open storage use it previously
historically will form part of the
employment site but now it doesn't have
an allocation but it does have um an
established open storage use
so through this application the
difference between them is that this has
now come forward the reason that this
has come forward on its own just the app
just this part of the site itself we've
been advised by the applicant is that
further information on the contamination
has come forward they've found that the
actual remediation costs for developers
in the site are much lower than they had
previously um expected them to be and
now this site can come forward on its
own for housing development without the
need for any housing development within
the green wedge so this proposal does
not consider any housing within the
green region solely within the urban
conference on previous developed land
so in terms of the other issues um
impact on neighbours the nearest
neighboring property is this property
here which is number 70 to 78 um north
down road um in terms of the distance
from the nearest neighboring property or
the news proposed dwelling to their
garden is around 19 metres
and through a future reserve matters
application we can consider the window
locations within that property and make
sure there's any there's no significant
impact on their privacy in terms of
noise and disturbance the
existing road into the site is actually
in this location here and they're
actually relocating the road so it's
further away from the neighboring
property
the the neighbor did raise some concerns
but but really just with the boundary
treatment they have and the um impact
from it on the on their property because
of the limited boundary treatment they
had so there is a condition proposed
that recommends the erection of a new
two meter high fence along the boundary
and it's considered that given the
distance to the road um and the fact
that again it has an established lawful
use as open storage and therefore you
could have hdv vehicles using that
access now that the impact from the
development would have limited impact on
on their amenity
in terms of the future occupiers of the
development they are it's located next
to the railway so there has been some
noise assessments carried out and
there's some mitigation measures that
will be necessary when constructing the
units and in order to protect the
immunity of these units from the noise
from the railway
in terms of the um scale of units so the
scale and design is not being considered
at this stage but you can see within
with um on this plan they're actually
showing an initiative um scale of the
unit so they all would be proposed as
two-story so there's nothing exceeding
two-story in height
um
in terms of the open space as previously
mentioned this is now located in this
area here this would include an equipped
play area as well as general open space
to serve the development
the size of the open space complies with
the requirements within policy gi
and therefore the the provision of that
space is considered to be appropriate
in terms of affordable housing the
original application proposed only 26
affordable housing
um on the grounds that it was unviable
to provide anything further
the agent has reconsidered this and in
order to try and achieve the 30
provision in order to make a policy
compliance scheme the number of units
have increased during the application so
the original application came in for 60
and this is now for 65 units
um which has allowed the um agent to now
offer 30 affordable housing on site
um whilst we would normally look at a 70
30 split a 50 50 split has been offered
so 50 of shared ownership and 50
affordable rent which our housing team
have considered and and consider
acceptable as they are getting 30 on
site they're happy to consider that
split on viability grounds
in terms of the actual mix of units
there's a
a range of mix so there's a one bed two
bed and three bed and four bed units on
the site so
again when when increasing the number of
units from 60 to 65 the reason that this
has had limited impact on on the
carriage of the area is that some flat
blocks have been introduced so the
original scheme was solely for houses
there's now two flat blocks one in this
location here and one in this location
here which provides the one bed unit
which we have a great need for in terms
of the affordable units
this means that whilst the number of
units has increased in terms of actual
built form there's actually been a
limited increase in the number of
buildings across the site so the actual
impact from that increase of units has
had limited impact on the carriage of
the area
so in terms of considering the impact on
highways this is an air review just
showing again the current access into
the site so this is a current access in
this location here from north down road
you can see the bridge that goes across
the railway so the proposal is looking
to relocate the access into this
location here which will allow for
improved visibility into the site and it
will allow
them to achieve
2.4 by 40 meter visibility displays
as part of the scheme they're also
looking to widen the road
in this location here which will improve
visibility of vehicles coming over the
bridge so the road widening will go from
4.9 meters which is the current width to
6.8 meters in this location here
and they're also looking to propose
crossing points so in this location here
would be crossing points and then across
the actual access itself so this is the
highway plan
proposed so you can see the crossing
points in this location here and in this
location here this is the existing
access into the site this is now the
proposed access with the visibility
and i'll just show you this which is a
slightly more detailed so the existing
line of the road is this grey
dotted line here
and this is now the width of the road
here so you can see the the fact is
widened from this point here over to
here in order to improve that visibility
so you get a direct line of traffic
crossing the bridge and as you approach
the bridge there's also a localized
build out in this location here which
also will help with visibility
so ktc highways have
been consulted on the application
they've advised that when considering
the existing open storage use in
relation to the proposed housing
development there will be an increase an
increase in vehicle movements into in
the local area
and
the increase will be 2.8
on net flows in north down road and 1.37
in vicarage street
they consider that this increase is will
not result in severe impact on the
highway network and it's only a severe
impact that could allow us to refuse an
application on highway grounds
um
the
uh sorry in terms of the
uh vehicle movements during the day so
currently there's 10 to 15 vehicle
movements during the network peak so
this is increasing to 17 to 22 during
the morning and 10 to 15 during the
evening but again as as mentioned this
will not result not considered as a
result of severe impact on the highway
network so as you come out onto north
down road whilst there's some
concerns with vickery street the the
traffic would spread some will go
across to beacon road
and someone come down northern road and
then it was spread out so the actual
percentage increase in vicar street
where there are concerns is considered
to be limited
so the other consideration was the
impact on pedestrian movement so there's
currently an existing bridleway that
runs along this boundary here
um with the development of this site
it's quite likely there would be
increased need to for pedestrians to
access this area here where you have the
mocketswood surgery and you've got the
church you've got the co-op
so and pedestrian movement to this area
what was considered by
kcc public rights away um team
they have
requested the resurfacing of
bridal way
and um we've managed to secure a
contribution of 12 000 pounds which
would um resurface this part of right
away here up to the point where the
um path goes through rocket word so this
is the existing bridal way that leads on
to north down road so you can say it's
currently an unmade path
and this is the um
access that goes through
mockit's wood that leads to the surgery
so the
this area here would be resurfaced in
order to improve
the usability of that space for the
increased pedestrians from the
development
so all contributions of um that have
been requested are being secured through
um a legal agreement so we haven't yet
received the draft agreement which is
why it's dedicated for approval subject
to that the agreement coming in
um
the site is considered to to be a
sustainable site it's in close proximity
of saint peter's village you can easily
walk into the village where there are um
facilities and services it's previously
developed land within the urban confines
with the only part of the development um
that was within the green wedge being
developed is this area here which is the
low level planting and which offers a
biodiversity benefits and therefore
whilst there will be a lot of some
agricultural land the benefits to
biodiversity are considered to outweigh
that loss this area these are areas are
all protected by via condition so
it's not expected like through the
reserve matters
application no development could come
forward in this land because we are
actually proven layout through this
application so nothing more can come
forward as part of the reserve matter
scheme so if members were concerned that
there could be encroachment into the
green wedge that isn't possible through
this application because this is
would be approving this layout as it is
not anything further obviously in the
future they look to come in with any
housing within the green wedge that
would be a separate application to be
considered and we will again consider
that through the policy
but in terms of this actual application
the impact on the green wedge and
landscape character area is considered
to be acceptable given the fact that
there is retention of the tree screen
along the boundary and
the provision of that as a retained
buffer and then
enhancements through the new plant in
the trees along that boundary which will
help to soften the development
the remediation of the contamination is
considered to be a benefit along with
those biodiversity improvements and
whilst there is a increase in vehicle
movements these are considered to be
minimal
the 30 affordable housing is achieved
along with the contributions and
therefore is considered overall to be a
sustainable former development that will
contribute to the council's housing
supply and therefore it is recommended
that it be deferred and dedicated for
approval subject to the league agreement
and safeguarding conditions thank you
jeremy
uh thank you very much emma
i moved the office recommendation be
adopted could the vice chair please
second
i'm second nature i think accounts are
common counsel
thank you thank you for um thank you for
the thorough presentation as well
um
i have i mean i called this in because i
do have a number of concerns about this
this proposed
development and i'll just go through a
couple of them to start with anyway
um not in
necessarily in priority order
um
i am i have to say i'm extremely
surprised
about the um
[Music]
kcc statements about the roads
i mean i'm obviously
very familiar with those roads very
familiar with vicarage
road church street and with that
north down road over that bridge at this
at the moment
it is
uh chocka block
that is a one at one end of north down
road that that one-way
bridge
is a bit of a nightmare for local
residents
and for people who use it as a bit of a
cut-through coming from margate going to
taking their kids to the school
um and then at the other end vicarage
road church street
that is
points one and one way as well as was
mentioned by camille that's already a
dane two dangerous um problem roads
this is adding
well i didn't quite follow the
how the there's just a two percent
increase because if you look at with 65
properties
and even with one
one car in each house that's going to
add significant
volume and it's also going to add
significant issues at the turn in and
out of that
housing estate
from north down road
and despite that widening of the road
there i still think that will be an an
issue
um and i think if people if members
aren't aware of that and i suspect a lot
are
i would i would advise them to maybe go
and have a have a look
before considering approving this
um
my other
one of my other main issues around this
is around
this
site being on the edge of the green
wedge so to speak
you gave a bit of the history about
previous applications
and needing
a wider development on some of the
countryside to enable the contamination
of the site to be cleared and now we we
find that um
now it is viable without those extra
houses because
the contamination of the site
um can be dealt with for less money i
mean i am
concerned about that contamination as
as you've said it is an old
british gas works
um going back to pre-natural gas when
when gas was great created from um
produced from coal
i mean i know
the site is uh capped with concrete and
i don't
i haven't read anywhere that there is
where there's a clear understanding of
exactly what the gun contamination below
is although i do understand and believe
that this currently vented a couple of
points
um into a couple of the farmers fields
so what is that what that
release is from that contamination i'm
not sure so i can't i would like to
understand more about
how we can now be sure that this land
can be
decontaminated
for a lot less than what it was
previously
but uh get back to the green wedge that
that is a that there is a long strip of
land with a lot more of the land but
there is a stripper land that i know
that the mockit trust owned all the way
across the back of rockets wood
um the back of the churchyard all the
way along to um
what
the saint peter's road
um
and any further development i wouldn't
like to see any any approval of this
be seen
as sort of a green light
or go ahead for any further
incursion into the green wedge
being allowed to maybe help pay
for the contamination
or the decontamination of this
this site so i do i would i mean
obviously open to hear what others have
got to say about that and one minor
point you did talk about
um
the uh bridal weight that was being
upgraded to give more access to
footway through mockitwood i mean i do
know
familiar with mockitwood there's quite
quite a lot of pedestrian
footfall through there that has
caused some damage to that wood which as
was mentioned that
quite a large group of volunteers work
very hard type people and i do have a
concern about that footfall being
significantly
increased although i suppose if that's
done on the same way as um
kcc percentage increases that would be a
just a two percent increase in footfall
that we don't need to worry about
but um
yeah i'm interested to hear what others
have got to say
thank you thank you account sakana
councillor heart
thank you chair um
i have some concerns about this because
i
along with my esteemed counselor
councillor ghana i i know this area
reasonably well and um
it beggars belief that they want to move
the
the exit or entrance to this site even
closer to a bridge which you come over
any speed you can't see what's the other
side i think that's an absolutely
frightening and shocking
revelation um but i'd like to know what
the contamination of this site is what
is it heavy metals or what is it i just
want to know exactly what is it methane
gas whatever's given off i want to know
what that is and i want to know
um
that this green wedge which looks very
pretty on the left hand side of this
picture um
it's got water ponds in it and they're
all low-level vegetation which is
marvellous who's going to maintain it
how dangerous is that for the youngst
younger generation our kids or kids if
there's a puddle there they're going
splashing it can they get to it is it
accessible to the public um or is it
being
just left to be wilded
and
it is good that we're using or looking
at using brown field sites that's
wonderful everybody applauds that and
everybody wants to right the bridge does
concern me majorly and but i'm also want
to know what all the contaminants are
and how they're going to deal with it
and how they're going to make that site
safe thank you chair
thank you so i'll bring back emma
if you
i'm afraid i don't know what the actual
contamination elements are that within
the site but in terms of the actual
contamination
side of things um
i know that they submitted
um
initially um a document that looks at
the contamination and i know that we've
obviously consulted with the environment
agency and they raised concerns and not
enough information have been provided on
what
mitigation was going to be carried out
what for um in terms of the remediation
so a further report um was submitted to
a land contamination planning support
statement which provided a clear outline
of the remediation works that were
proposed so that's
is set up within the report so the base
repeats the summary of this was
there was excavation of hot spots of
contamination
the installation of 800 millimeters of a
capping layer within gardens and 300
millimeters millimeters within
landscaped areas
the installation of vapor membranes
within buildings with this passive
underfloor ventilation
um
and the use of
protective line barrier pipe work so
these are the things that have been set
out within the report obviously we've
gone back to environment agency and at
this stage they're happy
with the proposal with these objectives
more more information will need to come
in by the conditions that have been put
on the safeguarding conditions
um but at this point in time environment
agency and the council's contaminated
land officer are both satisfied that
enough information has been submitted
to um
say what works are potentially going to
be carried out in order to mitigate
obviously it will have to be mitigated
before people can live there it's a you
know for public safety purposes we have
to make sure the site is mitigated and
to adequate levels so that will happen
and that will come through the
conditions
in terms of your other point in terms of
landscaping so this application because
it's an outline form at the moment only
for layout and um access we don't
actually have a proper landscaping plan
so as part of reserve matters
application details of that space the
compensatory land will come in as part
of that reserve matters application so
we'll be able to see at that point
um
what how that land's going to be set out
in terms of the landscaping whether
there will be any paths going through it
or whether it's just going to be an
excluded space just for the drainage and
just for the low level planting in terms
of the management of that that will come
through a landscape management plan so
again there's a condition recommended
for a landscape management plan to come
in
um prior to any occupation of the
development that will look at how that
space will be managed into the future
in terms of the highway points you were
mentioning
i mean that the access is being
relocated in order to improve visibility
to that access point so highways have
said that that access is is safe because
you can achieve adequate visibility
i appreciate members concerns with the
increased
levels of vehicles that will come from
the site i do understand because you
know the bridge is quite
narrow there are
at the moment there can be queues
leading up to that bridge
but um highway is considered they've
often compared it to the existing
um use of the open storage use which you
know could have as many vehicles i don't
know the hot it's a large site that
could have open storage use so you could
have a lot of vehicles using this and
hdbs as well
and when comparing that they're saying
that the increase
won't be significant and we can only
object to something if there's a severe
impact on the highway network
yes i'm just going to bring ian back in
just from
sorry just to add tim's point with
regards to highway and capacity
obviously what highways are looking at
is not that all of these 65 dwellings
are suddenly going to go onto the
network at the same time i think that's
an important point in terms of the idea
of a percentage increase is looking at
the peaks and when there's more likely
to be more traffic on the road
just a reminder for members obviously
when it comes to matters to do with
highways and potential objections
it's really key that there's evidence
behind any objection on highways grounds
and
highways have gone back and forth on
this especially with regards to the
off-site works that are being proposed
to try and improve the pedestrian
crossing point as well as that access as
well
with quite a lot of negotiation on it so
thank you
uh thank you ian um cancer auburn
thank you chair uh just to start off
with in you know like everybody else and
danny i've used that road and that
bloody bridge
uh
on a number of occasions and nearly out
of but you know because people are
stupid
and uh you know try and go across there
too fast
i don't use it anymore i go around the
other way um but
i think that that is a concern and why
um and why kcc don't put a traffic light
system
on either side of that bridge is beyond
me i mean that that's the way of dealing
with that but that's just my point of
view
um
i think from the contamination side we
we have sites in
both margay and in ramsgate which were
old gas sites say the same as this which
are being which have been and are
currently being re developed
and the contamination has been dealt
with quite quite adequately there
and on on both the sites um
and and in the ramsgate one there is uh
there's an audi gone there
and there's housing to go on the other
part of the site
um
the site itself i believe is is
adequate
with the design that they've
subsequently
put in on
the other design i have to say no layout
did appear to be cramped
um this appears appears to be open i can
see no
reason apart from the highway issue
for
turning this down chair um so i would
support the
officer's uh recommendation thank you
thank you councilwoman you took words
from me about the gas works in
margate and ramsgate
yeah so
it shows you're as old as me
um councilman
thank you chair
um yeah i did have concerns about this
application but i have to say i i'm
very pleased to see that there is no
encroachment on the green wedge
um
personally where the highways issue is
concerned i
i could only see it as an improvement it
isn't good at the moment that's
absolutely true i can't believe that
highways would make a change that would
make it make visibility worse or more of
an issue so as far as i can see that's a
positive thing um
as as councillor albans said i believe
that the
society is fairly well well laid out
very pleased that
they've been able to reach
the 30 affordable housing not so happy
that it's 50
rental only but
you can't win them all perhaps um in
general i think having heard the report
that i'm happy to support this
application thank you
i thank you councillor bayford counter
clinton
thank you um having uh worked for many
many years out on the industrial estate
next to
the other side of this um i'm extremely
familiar with the bridge um i personally
unlike my colleague prefer to cross the
bridge rather than navigate trying to
get out of the other end into beacon
road i find it infinitely safer to
navigate the bridge
which is actually if you get into the
middle of it you can pass two cars in
the middle of it um however like council
lahar i am extremely concerned at moving
the access nearer that bridge
because not everyone does understand you
can pass two cars in the middle and
there is often a lot of queuing there
and i'm concerned that there are an
awful lot of family units in here that
are going to be um
going off to school work and things like
that that is going to put a lot of
pressure on that bridge um
and so i am very concerned that the
decision to to move the access uh to
that site
nearer to where people are
already quite a lot of people who do use
it are quite stressed by it um
as well as the pressures on turning out
into vicarage street which i think is no
church road is it at the other end
church street um
uh and potentially beacon road as well
so that that's my issue
thank you thank you i'm bringing back in
just for a moment on a couple of points
here council secretary
um just just to come back on the the
point about the access i i understand
i think it's it's clear there is a
concern about the bridge as it stands at
the moment i think just to clarify this
point about
the the access
what is trying to be achieved here by
moving the access away from the existing
access is so the cars actually leaving
the access can look to the left to see
over the bridge
to then be able to actually see to turn
out to the right
now obviously at the moment if you use
that existing access which again is
lawful
by virtue of open storage you can see
here where that access is on the plan
it's the one to the south where you've
got the uh there's the arrow actually
which points to it at the moment which
is pedestrian visibility
you if you look left you cannot see from
that existing access across the bridge
so any car turning off
would potentially have conflict with
users coming over the bridge
so the point here is that
you know we have a highway arrangement
with the bridge itself that is is less
than ideal but fundamentally it's about
whether or not the new access actually
results in a a potential highway safety
harm now there's actually an improvement
in terms of visibility in terms of where
that access is that's fundamental it's
it's been evidenced by the highway
professionals in terms of looking at
visibility so
we aren't i don't think there's a
there's a value necessarily disputing
that i get the fact though that members
are concerned about this there are
obviously the council's made a
suggestion with regards to
in the future is it possible to have
traffic lights for example on the bridge
you know that is something that highways
obviously um can look at uh is something
that obviously comes through actually
kcc councillors in terms of providing
potential
programmes for funding or use of funding
that they're allocated so it is
something that could be looked at in the
future but it's not a requirement that
kcc
suggests is as a result would justify as
a result of this particular proposal
thank you chair uh thank you ian i can't
see
sorry council ghana you're down there
yeah
thank you it's interesting hearing what
others have got to say i re i realize
this is in
this is for outline approval
and uh
there there will be an follow-on
application at some stage in due course
to deal with reserve matters
and i've heard what people have said
about other british gas sites that have
been successfully developed i mean i'm
sure none
none no two sites are the same they
might have been used differently they
might have different types of
contamination i would if if the
committee does decide in its wisdom to
approve this outline application
i would like to see
at the reserve matters
application
details about what the contamination is
and how it's being dealt with before
any houses are being built and being
occupied because i
am
quite
sure
that
there are vents
from beneath this site into farmland
around the site that are releasing
methane occasionally
and that
that
when it was four or five years ago
it wasn't a viable site to be
decontaminated without building extra
houses now it is a viable site
apparently to be decontaminated without
building extra houses i think we need to
know exactly what the details of that
contamination they are and how that is
being done
thank you thank you
i think very valid point and i'm sure
you will be uh
you will be the opportunity will be
there as it is for all of us when it
comes about
yes i'll just bring back here and then
i'll come to council heart
thanks just to clarify for cancer ghana
in terms of what you're saying about
contamination so
there is a
a precedent condition that's proposed
which is a condition 7
which requires
basically an additional risk assessment
to come in
with a model then goes through site
investigation results that site
investigation and detail risk assessment
based in a remediation strategy all of
that has to go through the council's
contaminated land officer as well as the
environment agency which has been
requested by the contaminated land
officer now that is timed that basically
you can't start development on the site
until that's come in it's gone back and
forth and it's been signed off
it's not proposed to come through the
reserve matters application but to your
point the site can't be developed it
can't be occupied until that remediation
strategy has been agreed and has been
carried out and there's a verification
report that's required as part of that
as well and all of that has to go
through both the contaminated land
officer and also the environment agency
so we feel like it's covered but it
wouldn't come forward as part of the
reserve matters but it has to happen
before any development takes place on
the site
thank you
council grindham
um i i just want to come back on on this
access point um i do feel very strongly
that actually
if only people had come down and
actually looked at it that moving it
closer to where it is actually will make
it more dangerous um getting in and out
of there i know how cars use that road i
know how because i use it all the time
and i just hope that if this goes
through
tonight then
that can be taken into consideration
when any future applications are done
and any reviews of it that it would
actually
get a more detailed look at because i
really do from my my regular use of that
junction
um i really do believe moving that
junction nearer there is going to make
it more dangerous i do feel that very
strongly
thank you
for that uh
councillor heart thank you chair i i do
agree with council christendon and a
couple of others here i i think this is
a very dangerous
um precedent here that moving that
junction even close to that bridge makes
it more dangerous i understand ian's
comment that if you're gonna turn right
you can see better quite possibly you
can you've got a big keep clear sign
there so you won't be able to
actually get your car onto there you've
got to either stay back and everyone's
going to go further forward because they
want to actually get across the bridge
and i think
unless
can we put something into the into the
application that makes kent county
council
or highways whoever deals with it
actually look at this after it's gone in
to make sure it's a safe and
sensible junction because
all there's quite a few of us here that
all use this road we're all concerned
about that and
last thing i want is some kid running
out or some parent with a child in their
car being hit by somebody coming across
that bridge because somebody's deemed it
safe to put the road even closer to the
bridge and i think if we could put
something in there to actually
to mitigate that to make sure that
highways actually look at it and make
sure it is deemed safe and if not put in
proper proposals to sort it out then i'd
be happy to accept the um
recommendations thank you chair thank
you council heart
um i'm not sure whether officers are
coming back because i am aware that
what one second please
i know there's a walk
way through bridge isn't there
um so there's um as those off-site
highways works that would be subject to
a section 278 agreement um there would
be an assessment by highways about the
works that's going on generally um we're
just double checking
um the details of the application about
whether or not a safety order has
already been carried out
on it
in terms of approving the development um
that is something that has been checked
in terms of whether or not it
constitutes a safe access um if you give
us if we could just have a very short
two minutes just we can just go through
the highways comments to just check this
point if that's okay
you can have
a two minutes very short two minutes
counts for auburn
a short two minutes
thank you members i hope you're more
comfortable now thank you i'm going to
hand over to
i'm going to hand over to you
thanks um apologies members just wanted
to double check um in terms of um
condition six which requires that no
sorry 16
uh that required no works would take
place until offside highways works um as
as illustrated have been completed um
what we um
would add to potentially add to that
condition is uh in accordance with a
safety or audit in coordination with kcc
highways now as mentioned as part of the
works to the highway they need to get
agreement from kcc which means that this
will be looked at but to make it
explicitly clear
what i would suggest is that we simply
add that wording in about the
requirement for that safety order into
condition 16. um i appreciate that the
motion on the table has that wording the
condition but given that this has been
mentioned if the chairman and the vice
chair have forwarded it put it forward
and seconded that motion would agree to
changing that motion uh change that
particular condition to add in the
safety order um then then we would
certainly endorse that
thank you ian will
cancel
sorry
sorry just to come back on ian's point
which we all we all appreciate thank you
for your time um would that be would
that safety audit come in after the
houses have been built or before
before won't it so it won't really make
most difference at all so realistically
they're not going to check on it after
the 46 or whatever it is houses have
been built so it really is going after
the house has been built i mean
yeah um well the
the safety it would look at it's not so
much that the works the offside
hardworks have to actually be completed
before the development takes place so it
will look at the use of that access when
it's actually occurring but but
the the requirement that i was asked for
is basically the works are completed to
the highway before the development
starts to ensure that all of the impact
of the development is mitigated so you
don't have the existing access being
used whilst the houses are getting
occupied so what we'd suggest is that we
we get the safeguard in place so that we
just get the audit to be checked by
highways um this preliminary design
would have gone through a likely a phase
one safety audit but it is something
that that could be looked at with the
very detailed design at phase two
usually is looked at by highways so for
example
any roundabouts when they're delivered
obviously have a preliminary design that
we look at a planning stage but then
when you get to a section 278 highways
agreement you get the real detail of
exactly where the footpath ends and
exactly where the telemetry goes
so what we would look to do is add it
into this condition which means that
before the works are carried out to both
the junction
as shown here but also ensure that
before any development happens on the
site that access is safe so that's when
we would try and time the development
right i'm quite happy to
because ghana
sorry sorry to come back i was it's just
some well talking about the access on
the roads there's one thing
that i just wanted to also mention that
we haven't considered which is the
construction phase for this this um
development
um there's going to be an awful lot of
large construction traffic
needing to access
that site they won't i've assumed won't
be able to access it over the
single track humpback bridge
because they might get stuck in that so
they'll only be able to access it from
the bottom
on
church street vicaridge road which is
all
already a sort of single file
land i just wanted to ask what
consideration have been given to that
police thank you good point it's under
condition 15 so very specifically again
before any development takes place
there's a need for a construction
management plan again that would be
checked with highways
obviously the existing use of the site
may well use hdvs or could use hdbs for
for open storage but we we do think
again the construction management plan
which is
you know standard requirement for
housing on this scale but it is
particularly important with this site
because of where this access is and the
existing access as well so again that
would be something that would need to go
through highways to be agreed again to
ensure that it's things it does include
stuff to do with say you know timings of
deliveries because obviously again in
terms of the build up on that junction
etcetera to ensure that they're phased
in a particular way but but we do
consider that condition 15 would would
cover those points to go to highers
thank you chad
uh thank you in
right i do propose that um the addition
for the the safety um
you know the junction is looked at
further has been explained by mr
livingston to the vice chair
please second that
oh second nature thank you and i'm sure
you
you agree
right come to the main motion which is
uh
um for the officers recommendation to
defer and delegate uh for approval those
in favor
those against
any abstentions
thank you members that is carried thank
you and a very good debate again thank
you
ryder final item on the agenda tonight
is an application for deferral of
princess margaret avenue in
margate which is agenda item 5c
speaking in favor of the application and
apologize for keeping mr
ms humber i beg your pardon um
quite a long time tonight but
miss humber you have three minutes
uh good evening chairman and members of
the planning committee
thank you for allowing me to address the
committee tonight
i can hopefully keep this brief as um
planning matters have been very well
covered by the planning officer in the
report for you tonight
um i'd like to introduce myself my name
is sharon
i'm sorry i'm a bit nervous here
and i've lived at number 41 princess
margaret avenue for 15 years with my
partner amanda
and our five children
four which are still at home
one is going to kent university shortly
and three remain
and they are in local secondary schools
41 princess margaret avenue is our dream
forever home and we have been very happy
here
we thought it was important to be active
in our local community by supporting our
schools where um
where i
sorry became a local school governor at
palm bay school where all of my children
went to
my partner and i both worked for the nhs
i took retirement in the beginning of
2020
but returned very quickly when uh kobe
became very rampant
and really to support the local qeqm
hospital which was
significantly overwhelmed
um
i was also hospital
governor for four years prior to
retirement
i remain there today part-time but i
have plans to fully retire
and as especially as amanda is
approaching retirement too
our eldest daughter has finished her
last year at university in london and
plans to live locally which we're very
pleased about
and we see this new dwelling um as a way
of creating a legacy for our children
and helping our elders onto the property
ladder and to lessen her debt
we have worked closely with all of your
planning officers who have been very
helpful in this process
and we have amended our plans to
overcome the concerns from our
neighbours
we do feel that small affordable
dwellings in established and desirable
residential areas such as ours
are hard to find and
this new home will help um to meet an
identified local housing need by
granting planning permission for this
property it will help the council to
meet their housing targets and will help
to alleviate the pressure of building
new homes in the countryside
it's a modest new dwelling
will not detract from the character of
the area or not harm the amenities of
the neighbours
the materials we plan to use will be of
high quality and sustainably sourced and
hopefully local i believe in that
the new landscaping will be
biodiversity enhancement and we will add
permeable paving bird boxes water butts
to finish the property
together with an electrical vehicle
charging point
um as the planning report confirms his
proposed development will meet all the
aim aims of sustainable development and
i truly believe that the proposed
development does comply with government
planning policy and with our um with
authentic local plan
so thank you for your time tonight for
listening
uh thank you very much i know it's
difficult not to be nervous um
i've been possibly corrected here is it
miss humber
worry thank you that's on my
paper here and congratulations for the
work you've
been doing for the nhs and i think we
all would agree on that
um
speaking as your ward councillors i have
two wall councillors council please
please
uh thank you chair
um there are a number of concerns that i
have with the proposal that i'll be
grateful for the committee to consider
firstly as it's been pointed out in the
inject on the objections on the portal
there are serious concerns with
overlooking into neighbouring properties
where the windows are proposed
regardless of if you frost them once
opened will obviously be overlooking for
established properties
secondly the report acknowledges that
the footprint of the proposal is smaller
than the surrounding properties indeed
documents on the portal namely street
scene 3 4 and 9 show exactly how much
smaller the proposal is
the report states that this is mitigated
by the proposal being set back set back
further than the properties on the road
i believe that this will make little to
no difference and will actually end up
highlighting the differences between the
houses
i'd urge members to look at these
documents carefully and ask themselves
if this is in keeping with the rest of
magnolia avenue
further to this point street seat nine
demonstrate demonstrates exactly how
much of the garden for number 41
princess margaret avenue decreases
this property has a garden and
subsequent amenity space commensurate
with its size
to approve this application would mean
the garden of number 41 princess
margaret avenue more than halves in size
reducing the level of biodiversity in
the area with it
if i could close by quoting uh the
reasons for refusal the last time this
came forward
the proposed development by virtuous
location layout scale design and
subdivision of the existing plot and the
relationship with adjacent neighbours
would result in a cramped and discordant
form development within the street scene
i believe this statement remains true of
this application would urge the
committee to write votes to refuse thank
you
okay thank you councillors councillor
towning do you wish to add to that or
you have further comments
thank you chair
evening committee
um
my colleague ovie has raised a number of
issues regarding this particular site
the development is in an area where
and there's already considerable amount
of congestion with cars
in order for you to give it a
proper
consideration your professional
consideration i would suggest that you
know a site meeting might throw better
light
on the actual development of this other
development on
on the back of the garden
it's certainly
they have been um developments in other
people's back gardens over the years but
this certainly does throw up a lot of
other problems that will come with that
development and i would recommend to you
to consider a side visit thank you
thank you councillor town in we can't
decide on site visit at this stage um
that might come later but ask um
our officer which is emma to outline
this report please liberal
thank you chairman the application site
is is outlined in read on this plan so
this is magnolia avenue um to the north
of the site and you can see princess
margaret avenue to the east of the site
so the
land is currently forms the rear garden
of number 41 princess margaret avenue
this is an aerial view of the site so
this is the application site here so you
can see
the garden depth you can see the
surrounding character of the area so in
terms of plot sizes the properties at
front princess margaret avenue are quite
large detached units with quite deep
plots but as you come into magnolia
avenue
they are mainly bungalows and the plots
in some cases are slightly smaller
especially on the southern side of
magnolia avenue
in this location here you can see the
opposite the site is
an existing
bungalow unit
so this is a more detailed aerial view
of the site so again this is the
application site here so there's a
substation in this location between um
number 28 and the application site so
the proposal is for the subdivision of
this garden area for the erection of a
dwelling in this location here
so this is photos taken from magnolia
having you looking towards the
application site so the application site
is in this location here the properties
on the right hand side of this photo are
the bungalows with vegan magnolia avenue
and then this is taken from princess
margaret avenue looking towards the
application site which is on the
left-hand side here
and then this is now back in magnolia
avenue looking towards the application
site in this location here to the left
of the substation
a view of the substation and the
existing boundary treatment to the front
of the site
again from magnolia avenue with the
application site on the right hand side
here
and then this is the site opposite the
site so you can see this is the existing
bungalow opposite and the rear garden of
the other property on the corner of
princess margaret avenue
that this is now within the application
site itself so you can see the depth of
the garden looking towards number 41
princess margaret avenue
and this is showing neighbouring
properties within princess margaret
avenue and the existing boundary of the
site in this location here
and then looking back towards
the properties of magnolia avenue and
the substation behind this hedging area
here
and then this is just showing um the
general character of properties within
magnolia avenue which as you can see are
all smaller bungalow units
but you can see there's quite small
spaces between the units as well
so this was the previous application
this is the layout plan for that
application the previous application was
refused for three reasons
and one of those reasons was to do the
cramped development of the site and the
fact that the um it was quite a modest
size unit which was considered to be out
of keeping with and the pattern of
development
um and the limited spacing to the
boundaries from um from the unit
the second reason was related to
overlooking from rear roof lights within
the rear elevation of this um
of the proposed unit and into the rear
garden of the properties in princess
margaret avenue and the third reason was
a technical reason linked to the lack of
a unilateral undertaking to secure the
spa contribution
these were the
floor plans for the previous application
so you can see in terms of the first
floor layout and in terms of the
overlooking issue there was a v-duct
window that served a bedroom to the rear
and a v-duct window that served a
bathroom to the rear so the rear window
serving the bedroom would have been a
clear window and there was concern that
that would have resulted in overlooking
so the proposal is now this before you
so there is limited change to the um
proposal in terms of the size of the
plot or the actual location of the
boundary treatment in terms of the um
changes the proposal has been set back
from magnolia avenues as a one meter
setback compared to the previous which
was in this location here so there is a
more spacious frontage to
the development
um in terms of the rear elevation
there's also been changes to the windows
and the first floor layout
so this is the layout plan of the
proposed units you can see the
substation on the left hand side here
the proposed footprint of the proposed
dwelling parking for one vehicle to the
front of the site here and then the
boundary achievement that will subdivide
the plot from number 41 princess
margaret avenue
this is the proposed elevation of the
unit so it is a shallow bungalow style
which is similar in ridge height to the
existing bungalows in magnolia avenue
and this is the side elevation facing
the property in magnolia avenue
and this is the rear elevation with the
roof flights that are still proposed but
you'll see in a minute they now serve
different
rooms
and this is the elevation that faces
back towards number 41 princess margaret
avenue so you can see there's no first
floor windows within that elevation
so this is the ground floor plan so
there's a bedroom
at the front of the ground floor and at
first for a level the rear bedroom has
now been turned into a dressing room and
ensuite area to serve the master bedroom
so it's now proposed that these two
reduxes which are high level reduxes
would be obscure glazed and there's a
safeguard condition requiring that that
would occur
and you can see the roof plan off with
the uh v-lux location
um in addition we've had um additional
information submitted including these um
these visuals of the proposal so you can
see here quite clearly the spacing that
would occur between the units
so in terms of the spacing between the
plots it's considered that this spacing
is acceptable especially given the
limited spacing between the properties
in magnolia avenue
and then another view there is a street
elevation level so again in terms of the
height you can see that the ridge height
is similar in height to the properties
in magnolia avenue
and then again another view of the
proposal so in terms of design as well
the um design similar with a small
single story front gable projection
which again is characteristic of
features you can see we've had within
magnolia avenue and you can see the um
open frontage that is proposed with soft
landscaping to the front here with just
the hard surfacing for the single
parking space on the left hand side
and again this view here so in terms of
the previous application it was um
refused on the grounds that it was felt
it was quite cramped there has been
minor changes which have resulted in the
setback of the unit which has increased
the spaciousness to the front of the
unit and the concerns regarding the
impact on the neighbours have been
addressed and the
applicant has agreed to the provision of
the spa contribution so if this were to
be recommended for approval by members
that will come forward as part of a
legal agreement and following following
tonight
in terms of the actual site and the plot
there is still considered to be harm to
the surrounding pattern of development
of the area because the plot is still
small so the plot as you can see is to
this location here with this fence here
so it is a small plot which is smaller
than other plots in the in the locality
um
the setback of the dwelling would bring
it
in in line with the front building line
that you can see along magnolia avenue
and in terms of the street elevations
that we've seen it would be a street
frontage development would fit in quite
well in terms of the street elevation so
the main concern is the fact that there
would be is quite a limited
plot debt so it is a balanced case this
one
previously we felt that with the
projection of the frontage of the
property towards magnolia avenue it
appeared too cramped with that setback
and with the other issues addressed it's
considered that on balance the harm to
the character appearance of the area is
not considered to be significant
although it is accepted that there will
still be some harm to the surrounding
pattern of development of the area so on
balance it is recommended for approval
subject to the submission of the legal
agreement thank you
uh thank you emma i move the officer's
recommendation is adopted the vice chair
police second oh second nature thank you
members
council ghana
thank you i'd like to go first because
i've been first on the other one so i
wanted to keep
a clean sweep of the whole
track record to keep up
i mean i have to say
i have to say with with with all due
respect to my um
cliftonville east councillor colleagues
i can see that quite a lot of thought
has gone into
into making this an acceptable
um
an acceptable
development
in magnolia avenue
um
it looks
quite nice quite good to me it fits in
well
um
i will say of course i do i do like
the um
addition of a electric vehicle charging
point although that is a obviously a
minor point
to take into consideration
um
the the argument about biodiversity gain
or loss
i mean i it looks pretty even to me if
not a bit positive because we've we've
lost although we've gained that
the property we've lost the swimming
pool which wasn't a particularly
biodiverse
addition to the plot
um
so
as you say it's quite a
quite a
a balanced thing but i'm
i'm happy to um
agree with the officer on this and i
will
unless i hear anything to persuade me
otherwise
i shall um be support in this
application thank you uh thank you
carlos carl my counselor heart
thank you chair i must hatefully um
disagree with my counseling mr garner um
i i think it's over developed cramped
uh it's just a shame to lose a nice
garden for
very noble let's be honest to build your
children a house in the garden that's
fantastic noble idea but realistically i
think
it's not right for that it's a nice it's
not even a huge garden the garden suits
the house and to to have
realistically a handkerchief garden for
a house of that size i think it's a
great shame and and to actually put
something in that's that cramped in that
area i can't see that it's suitable at
all i'm awfully sorry
thank you any other members
no
okay well i'm going to put this to you
members the office recommendation is to
defer and delegate and approve
those in favor please show
those against
abstentions
that has been carried thank you members
said
please don't go away but that has been
carried
yourself
that really